Bob as you watched us adjust our camera
i'm curious well DIY filmmaking become
the end of Hollywood Oh certainly will
move it somewhere else than where it
seems to want to go and I know it would
be the end of Hollywood I think it'll be
a new kind of movie on a personal movie
and much to be valued I think that
George yourself do it your own camera do
it on an iPhone do it on wherever you
can certainly is going to change then
you know the nature of movies under
George Lucas was saying recently that
he's dismayed at the nature of Hollywood
today and smade it's a kind of
big-budget some kind of razzmatazz which
is not personal I think that taught
yourself movies are inherently more
personal and so whether or not the end
of Hollywood or a new beginning it
certainly will change things that's
that's really all I could say about when
you say that you know we we watch movies
to see the human experience and feel
things and now we've gone away from now
we have social media which seems like it
would be part of the human experience
with it's actually not I mean we're
representing ourselves online in a
certain way that we want everyone to see
us as so that's not real but do you feel
that because the reality has become so
distorted that people want to make their
own films that get back to that in terms
of the reality TV is not that it's I
think there's a real hunger no there's
foot to return to those kinds of things
and if you can't do it in a big-budget
film which seems harder and harder to do
so far as I can see because someone
would get involved with huge budgets you
have to worry about mass audiences and
you have to worry about what will play
in Bombay as well as what a play in
queens so I do think that
you know independent films are returning
us to that experimental mode we're in
way back in 1895 that in a weird way
2015 is not so different from 1895
because nowadays you have all these
people trying out new things find new
ways new machines and devices so I'm
optimistic what it's going to do the
Hollywood exactly you know I I couldn't
really say I think that however
something good will come out of all of
the stuff
you